heute zu einem neuen video witsch und
ingame ich bin nicht alleine sondern das
ist wie wir spielen heute ein spiel ihr
seht schon eigene freunde play
battlegrounds das beste spiel des jahres
luca ich habe jetzt mehrfach gesagt das
funktioniert ganz schön was liebe dein
charakter gedacht da freunde hier wird
schon mein charakter hier unten ich habe
mir ein etwas breiteres ausprobiert weil
ich halt gedacht habe
heute fragt was ist überhaupt ein spiel
ist das jetzt der anderen battles ground
es geht darum dass wir gleich auf eine
riesige map geplant werden und da hin
zum beispiel in zeit und das hier bin
ich ihr müsst jetzt auf jeden fall mit
dem flug vergleich irgendwo abspringen
und ab dort kämpfen region leben meiner
des imf fordert 510 alter mann muss sich
in welt
mir schwindelig alles gut ich hab ich
hab so was wie gesagt du standard welche
mir zu turbulent werden
danke dir ewig wird aber mal sagen an
der stelle wenn wir jetzt der boden ist
lava relativ gut gelaufen
der boden war warum bist du so gut darin
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aus der bundesliga nein ich habe nichts
gemacht gibt eine mod da kann man die
blöcke abbauen blöcke das ist minecraft
hat genau die mit der zone geht um
endlich jemand auf der busfahrt oder
irgendwie so wie ja der boden ist
[Musik]
wandelbar
die schritte
das tut mir nach oben der boden sei
[Musik]
weiter gefahren nachdenken
wir kommen mit laube friedlich lösen
können sagt ihr genau bleiben und hier
eigentlich aber noch etwas anderes und
ihr wart ihr ganz großer von meiner
mutter vorbei schauen hallo mama von
reben zeit darf ich reinkommen unsere
familie ist natürlich viele fenster ja
es wird das badezimmer übrigens der
boden war 54 32
[Musik]
der boden ist live nicht reflektiert
aufhören möchte ich mit micra
verbindlicher open der bunten im
anschluss muss hierbei komme ich an was
dagegen hilft ich auf der runden form
von gelben haus hinein kann jedes haus
wir brauchen eine klare ja machen wir ja
da oben game haus weg immer karin alte
gedroht wir können dem sport worten
versuchen damit fahren dann ist das wie
ein sack alter
[Musik]
mai getötet
aufgrund der conwert sei heute zu töten
ich habe absolut keine ahnung alter
junge gestorben
der senator
nein wirklich nicht sein
ich war das nicht man hat mich einer
kleinen jungen
[Musik]
es wäre unnatürlich lang meist einfach
anderthalb mal so lang wie ein mensch
keine heute warenträger junge wir wollen
mit baby nicht zum fenster geben ich zum
fenster bode slava 543 immer noch voll
unserer fans wird er von dort lassen es
einfach mal ausprobieren ja warte ich
muss etwas fotografisch identifizieren
und immerhin das kleinen und großen
bakken festlegen kosten ändert die
bringt noch einmal schmerzmittel ein
ähnliches alter als auch die klare regel
studie 24 7 und hat einfach noch keine
person getötet ich habe zwei getöteten
[Musik]
wie basta hinter dir genau da erwarte
lassen könnten noch mehr sein als die
schweizer wirklich ein stück seife
gerade einfach
hier gibt keine autos wo hat gesagt bei
dem gelben haus gibt es autos gibt ja
verschiedene gelbe häuser
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wenn uns einer sieht also wie wichtig
gerade planen alter hilfe machen ihr das
eintreten damit fand schau mal heiß kann
sehr gut man ist ein autor und vorbei an
weiter wir nehmen uns jetzt ein auto
alter junge wir müssen erstmal langsam
vorgehen meint die leute von
innovationen auf dem airport ist dass es
bis heute weiter fahrt auf dem flugplatz
ab streit hat bekommt bestätigen die
abschlussposition
es kann sein dass vielleicht gegner
kommen da mussten anhalten und dann
natürlich die festwochen auto ein paar
wochen autos sollen ok wat du eine
andere kämpfer aufeinander zugehen
umdrehen und da haben wir unsere
nach bagdad gebracht erlag mal die typen
jetzt töten
[Musik]
heilig heilig heilig
das ist natürlich erst wirklich gewinnen
der pole war 5434 position
die studentin scheint wird über
gescheiterte holzschlitten
ich habe meine damen und herren alle
player playground battle auf wir haben
auf reddit kanal auch ein video davon
aufgenommen das heißt er kann es auf
jeden fall nicht in der beschreibung
verlinkt werden euch da ganz gefallen
hat das game an leica wenn ihr mehr
davon haben wollten
[Musik]